part of the pain of growing older is
that we can start to see how much at
certain points we misunderstood
ourselves what the costs of missing
self-knowledge were and how beautiful it
could be if we could just build
ourselves a time machine and go back and
correct all our mistakes
it's because at the age of seven we had
no idea about standing up to an adult
that we let ourselves get trampled upon
by a parent and then grew up as a target
for bullies for much of our lives
it's because at 17 we were so uncertain
about our value that there was no way we
could seduce someone we liked and wasted
what might have been some of our most
promising years in loneliness and
self-hatred
it's because at 30 we couldn't
understand how our romantic tastes had
been formed by our family histories that
we embarked on an in cautious
relationship that spoilt multiple lives
the better responses when we do finally
achieve them are so simple as to be
almost insulting
we may realize far too late that we need
to believe in ourselves overcome the
snobbishness of our parents
correct the distorted images we have of
figures of authority
stop worrying what others think
live by our own values and be free
if only we could land our elegant time
machine next to our younger selves and
whisper them such advice we'd have left
home with our dignity intact we'd have
had the love we craved we'd have spared
ourselves relationship agonies it's so
tantalizing no wonder we often stay up
late fantasizing about being able to go
back in our time machine knowing then
what we know now but not picking up key
lessons wasn't a casual oversight
wise lessons were around but we weren't
ready our inattention was inevitable
rather than accidental
we might have laughed defensively if
someone had suggested going to
psychotherapy aged 17 we would have
called emotional intelligence
psychobabble we were wedded to our
illnesses
we might try to be kinder to ourselves
by recalibrating how easy certain
emotional steps ever really are
they can certainly be summed up to sound
simple
but there is nothing at all simple about
correcting mental unwellness
it can legitimately be the work of a
lifetime to one day be able to feel
fundamentally content with ourselves not
scared all the time reconciled to our
careers and holding the hand of an
ordinary kind clever person who loves us
and whom we love
that only ever looks easy
in reality there's nothing more
complicated in the universe
our online shop has a range of books and
gifts that address the most important
and often neglected areas of life click
now to learn more
you